Alright guys, let's go ahead and close the deal.
So as we talked about in the last lesson, once we get through, we're going to finish
off the shit sandwich, which is we're going to end on a positive note before we go for
the close, right?
So the bun, which is good, the shit, which is the price, which they can view as a negative.
And then the bun, which is good, and then the price.
So remember, shit sandwich should be pretty easy to remember, right?
So what I do right before I ask for the deals, I lay out everything that they get, okay?
So I like to look at all the things and separate them, all the stuff that they get.
So I'm going to go, alright, so let me just tell you, just so we're on the same page,
Mr. Business Owner, this is what's included in the deal, okay?
So first thing is, it's 100% exclusive, okay?
Like I'm not sending these to anybody else.
As long as you're working with me, you're working with me.
Nobody else in this area, okay?
Or concrete, okay?
We also get, you also get the tracking number on the website.
Guys, I know that you're like, no, that's a no-brainer, but guys, if you separate each
of these pieces, think about, I think Alex Hormozi talks about this in his book.
You separate all of these individual pieces.
If they were to do a tracking number with just a regular service like CallRail, I think
it's like 50 bucks to do a basic plan, right?
So it's a $50 a month value.
So I'm adding that.
So I'm going to go back into it.
So we also get the tracking number option, which it's really cool because, not the option,
sorry.
We also get the tracking number on the website, which is super cool because we can forward
this directly to your number, which is what we're going to do.
And it's going to give you a whisper message to you.
You'll know exactly what calls are coming from this website.
Plus it's going to record everything and we have a bunch of other capabilities.
Like if we want to do a round robin or let's say you don't answer because you're on a job,
we can then send it to your secretary or your sales guy.
Like there's a lot of cool stuff with that.
So you also get the tracking number.
It doesn't cost you any additional money.
And then I'll let them know and you get access to our dashboard.
And I'm thinking in my head, CallRail, right?
And you can let them know.
So with the dashboard, you're going to be able to log in and view all the recorded calls.
You're going to be able to see the call flow.
You're going to be able to check out the leads.
You'll have your own login to our platform, which again is CallRail.
Then I will mention, I'll say, Hey, we also, not only are we going to be ranking in the
organic section for the actual website, but we're also, and I'm going to need your help
a little bit with this, but we're also going to be able to get in that map section.
So we're going to build out a map listing that goes hand in hand with this.
You're going to get all the leads that come from that as well.
And there's companies out there, Mr. Business Center, they only do that.
So they'll charge you just to manage that.
So we're going to do that as part of our deal.
And don't guys, don't make this sound like they're going to get that as their own.
This is part of the lead gen deal, but just let them know they get the leads from that
as well.
Okay.
So yeah, we're going to do that.
It's called GMB or I guess it's a Google, it's GBP, Google Business Profiles.
And probably when you watch this, it's going to be something else, right?
We're going to optimize that, put pictures and stuff.
We're probably going to need a little bit of help, but all the leads that come from
that you're going to get as well.
Okay.
So we will handle all that.
I am going to need you to help me with an address.
We'll talk about that in a minute.
And then here's the last thing is I'm going to give you first right of refusal on any
deals that we do in the area.
So like with Queen Creek, we're using that example.
So for example, Mr. Business Owner, like if I decide that we want to expand into Mesa,
before I go and just call another business owner that's your competitor, I'm going to
come to you first.
Then I'm going to say, Hey, Brian, do you have any interest in Mesa?
And you're going to have the opportunity to jump on and sign for that deal before anybody
else before I even talked to anybody else.
Okay.
Just so you know, that is teeing them up.
First of all, you're including it as a bonus or as a good advantage that comes with it,
which it is, but also you're teeing them up to say, Hey, this guy's looking to expand.
And when you hit them up and say, Hey, remember how I told you, I give you first right of
refusal?
Yep.
I'm going into Mesa.
Do you want any leads there?
And you automatically have them teed up to get second money, third money, fourth money
on these deals.
Guys, you see how brilliant this is, right?
Completely laid out perfectly.
Okay.
We are going to ask for the deal.
And here's how I do it.
I use what's called an assumption clause and it's actually kind of an assumption slash
option.
And so what an assumption clause is, and I know some of you guys have been in sales and
you're like, Oh my gosh, Nick, this is very basic.
An assumption clause.
It means you're assuming the sale.
You're assuming the deal.
So guys, what I'll do is I'll end, I'll mention all of the good things, right?
And then a high note, and then I'll just be really smooth and say, cool.
So all I got to do and I'll search around for my pen.
Like you could see me naturally.
I'll grab my pen or whatever.
I'll be like, let me grab my pen.
So all I got to do to get you guys, or to get you going is grab a card from you.
Are you an Amex or a Visa?
Okay.
And I'll just look down like I'm writing or I'll look right at the screen or I'll grab
my pen.
Like I'm getting ready to write down the number and I'll wait.
Are you an Amex or a Visa?
Okay, wait.
And I'm telling you right now, if you've done the setup correctly and if you've done all
the steps correctly and you've sent the leads the way that we've taught and you've, you've
prospected the right person, you've done all of those things, it is going to shock you
when they go, give me one second.
Let me grab my card.
And you're going, oh my gosh, is this happening?
Oh my gosh.
Brain.
And you just don't get too excited.
I remember the first couple of times this happened to me, I started talking too much.
I was like, cool.
Yeah.
Sounds good.
So man, the other cool thing is this, the other cool thing is it's like, just relax.
Okay.
Just act like you do this every day.
And the first time you do this, you're like, holy shit, I just got this deal, baby.
Let's go.
And you want to fist bump, save it till the zoom calls off.
Okay.
Just be calm.
So yeah, no problem.
I'm actually just going to get everything set up while you're doing that.
And you're over there just biting your nails.
They're going to give you the card.
You're going to, and here's what you're going to do.
If you get the deal right here, and in the next video, we're going to talk briefly about
objections.
But if you get the deal right here, which you will more often than not, if you do this
correctly.
Okay.
And like, I'm talking most of the time.
What I would recommend you doing is just writing the information down and that's going
to lead us to two videos from here where I'm going to show you how to set this up in Stripe
or into another merchant account, whatever, but you're just going to write down their
credit card information, their code on the back, their expiration date, their first and
last name and their zip code on a piece of paper.
That's the easiest way to do it because I know some people where they're like, let me
send you an invoice.
I just asked them for the credit card.
I'm going to write the damn thing down on a piece of paper and I'm going to go set
it up.
Okay.
So right there, if you've done it correctly, you're going to get the deal.
And if you guys have skipped a step, you're going to find out and you're, they're going
to go, yeah, Nick, like, yeah, haha, that's smooth, man.
Haha.
I like that.
Right.
Some of them are going to say that they're going to go.
So here's what I'm going to do.
And you're like, oh, here we go.
And they're going to say, so I'm going to give me about a day.
I'm going to talk to my, my spouse or I'm going to talk to my partner and, and I'll
let you know.
And all of a sudden, as they start saying it, you go, oh shoot, I forgot about the partner.
Okay.
And that leads us into the video that we're going to talk about next, which is about objections.